Now, as you can see, keyboard input only allows firing in the cardinal and
ordinal directions from where the player is, i.e the red and black arrows here.
With this, players using mice as an input would get an unfair advantage. As you
can see where the cursor is here, a mouse player would be able to shoot in a
direction and at an angle that keyboard players wouldn't be able to use. In
order to level the playing field, what we do in GRITS is eliminate that
advantage by snapping the firing vector to one of the eight directions that
keyboard controls allow. So, if you click where the cursor is now, it would go
along the right-up vector. Each of the shaded regions corresponds to only one
firing vector. We started out the unit talking about how important it was to
make sure that every player had a fair experience. But an issue is, that mouse
players with the current code can actually fire in more directions than
keyboard players. So, what we need to do is take the actual mouse input and
snap it to one of the eight directions that the keyboards actually have access
to. In order to do this, we need to do a little bit more trigonometry. Now, in
order to snap the arbitrary directional vector that we're getting from mouse
input to one of our eight directional values that a keyboard player can use, we
are going to utilize a lookup table. This lookup table is already populated to
contain the eight directional vectors, unitized, that keyboard players have
access to. Now, the magic sauce here, is taking this arbitrary directional
vector and turning it into a lookup index that we can then query against the
lookup table. For us, we have a magical pixie of a function, called
getQuantizedAngleIndex. Now, I'll spare you most of the math that's inside of
this function, because really, our intent is not to teach you trigonometry. The
overview is this, we use the atan2 function to find the angle between the input
directional vector, and the x positive vector. This gives us an angle between
the two InRadians. We then use some nice fun little tricky math here to scale
that angle value into an integer between zero and seven. That zero and seven
value is passed back and used as an index inside of our lookup table. The
result gives us a directional vector that matches exactly what keyboard players
can use